unlocking your phone it's just amazingly
intuitive you just raise it look at it
and swipe right up to get started
that was apples Craig federighi
demonstrating the company's new face ID
technology Apple introduced three new
iPhones yesterday they included the
highly anticipated iPhone 10 the tech
giant also unveiled updated models of
the Apple TV in the Apple watch in 2007
Steve Jobs introduced a very first
iPhone remember this afterward Apple
unveiled a series of innovations this is
one device
[Applause]
today we're introducing the iPhone 3G
I'm really pleased to tell you today all
about the brand new iPhone 4s but we
really want to do is just talk to our
device that's a feature the iPhone 4s we
call Siri the 5s is the most
forward-thinking phone we've ever
created the team has made it really fun
and easy for you to teach your iPhone 5s
about your fingerprint and now with just
a touch you've paid
we've now sold over a billion of them
this makes this is iPhone tip it is the
biggest leap forward since the original
iPhone the iPhone 10 starts at $999
that's like a thousand dollars Apple's
iPhone 8 and iPhone 8 plus are less
expensive CBS News contributor Nick
Thompson is editor in chief of Wired
magazine and if you like that scruffy
look we do too you just got off the
red-eye from the table makes your
profile but is actually it's complaining
nobody's complaining thank you you look
great let's talk about the iPhone 10 the
big question is is it worth a thousand
bucks it is worth a thousand bucks if
you are an early adapter if your company
will pay for it and if you're okay with
having a few weeks where it's confusing
to swipe down swipe up push that thing
on the side we're all use to the system
that the iPhones have given us for the
last little while but it looks pretty
great so if you like new stuff
functionally yeah functionally yes I
mean so everything that iPhones do will
do better right it will take better
photographs it will have much better
much better processing speed and if we
weigh better an augmented reality which
is something that's coming and that is
one of the biggest changes inside of it
as a chip built inside of it
specifically for AR what I want most
from my next iPhone is a better Siri
mm-hmm we get a better Siri it will have
a slightly better Siri just based on the
processing speed but really if that's
your biggest concern you should probably
stick with one of the other models and
save some money but what about the know
no finger thing again which I actually
think it's kind of good because after I
did the finger thing guys I couldn't
remember which
now it is with your face your face is
always the same no which face to you my
face is basically always here so do you
think this is a good feature I think it
is a good feature it is simply I just
hold it up and it makes it a little more
quicken ideally the tech that's being
built there will be built for all kinds
of other devices and will start using
her faces will become very convenient
the real question is can it be spoofed
right I know what your face looks like I
do not know what your fingerprint looks
like so Apple went to great depths to
try to make sure that it's hard to spoof
it that somebody can't hold it over you
while you're sleeping
right that you can't just be sort of
forced while you're trying to look away
you have to actually look into it it
does use depth sensors so you can't fool
it with a picture but what previous face
recognition systems have shown is that
really smart people figure out how to
spoof it right so I could 3d print your
head Gail yeah maybe spoof your phone ok
and what about the Qi wireless charging
yes so that's that's actually
traditionally when these phones come out
they kind of make it harder to charge
right I've got a new port and you have
to throw away all your old this is
actually good not only because they
introduced wireless charging so you can
put it on a table but also they made it
fit in with the normal system so the
charters that already exist will be
compatible with iPhone instead of
building their own proprietary system
that nobody has and that confuses you
that was actually a nice example of
Apple what rails defy the idea that they
expressed that this is a new generation
the new so that so the notion is best
put by our GATT reviewer David Pearce is
that these aren't phones you look at
their phones you look through they
change the world around you and that's
the AR and so in a couple of years and
we use our phones very differently
they'll say this is the phone that set
us mmm Nick Thompson so great to have
you here
delighted to be charged last longer Nick